very thankful to the Bryan's for
bringing us here Brian almost got an A
in that class but I think he got nothing
bidets after my class that's what I
heard anyway but it's I'm really glad to
be here with Jake it's an honor to be
standing up here honestly with a former
student and talk about a project that
just began as you as your soon hear
about i will say i think our story is
really very much is well suited to the
context of the prize the saban prize and
as you're you're going to hear in the
next 35 minutes as we talked and then we
engage with you all we really want to
accent that how do you take an idea and
make it a company in fact i'm a little
miffed to be frank with you because I
wanted to make this prize retroactive so
we could get our hands on this 25,000
and Brian assured me that that was not
possible but we came down here anyway so
what we want to do is three things as
you can see in on the board behind me
just we're going to start with a very
brief overview of this idea the context
for the idea we'll spend most of our
time with 0 point to how about the idea
came to fruition on our way down here we
came up with a what we hoped would be a
top ten list but we couldn't quite do it
so it's it's a dozen points that we
think tell our story in terms of how an
idea again became a company and then
we'll finish very briefly with a sort of
wrap up on this concept that you see
written behind me how we think this
concept and our company allows for
meaningful change well then transition
to QA and any questions you may have
about the nature of offsets their pluses
and minuses all those things we'll go
from there and we really look forward to
it and we're going to try to keep our
comments here very brief and mindful of
the clock I want to mention this as we
start that as you hear our story as you
think about how this idea came from a
college campus perhaps you all will
nurture ideas that come from your
University campus here it's important to
think about the context this idea
did not just come at any time it came at
the time of the climate crisis the
deepest crisis arguably humanity has
ever faced and so when this idea began
in the winter of 2005 it was at a very
fruitful time for our campus middlebury
in the broader context of what we all
now call the climate movement very
specifically that January a month before
this idea was was launched I had
organized a conference at Middlebury
that included 120 leaders of the nascent
climate movement it led to the book that
Brian summarized ignition what you can
do to spark a movement to fight global
warming and sparkle movement and our
campus I must say led by our
extraordinary undergraduates have really
been at the forefront of this climate
movement it's in that context that you
should think about brighter planet this
isn't just an idea that happened to show
up it's an idea that really wouldn't
have showed up had we not been at a
place full of ideas full of concern
about climate change and what to do
about it and full of frankly the belief
that we could do something but we had to
get at it right away and so that's the
context for how this began we began in
early februari of 2005 that's how this
idea got started and as brother planet
has gone along many of those other
students that I've been privileged
enough to know what Middlebury have gone
on to do other things taking great
leadership in the climate movement so
here's just one example some of you may
have heard of 350.org and this is the
second organization founded by some of
my former students in Bill McKibben
intended to help fight climate change
using the very entrepreneurial skills
that you all have no doubt used as you
came to Yale and no doubt or mastering
here this organization building on step
it up another organization again founded
by Middlebury folk is on the front
line of this movement and right now
Middlebury students along with soon Bill
are in Poland leading this fight to
following the advice of Jim Hansen try
to turn around our increased climate of
co2 concentrations in the atmosphere
bring it down within our lifetimes
hopefully down to 350 so again that's
the context for what we're going to talk
about so back to februari 2005
Middlebury was at this time of great
fruition thinking about solutions and
our founding began and our founding as
Jake is about to tell you was nothing
more than idea an idea that was brought
into a classroom and went from there
thanks John so we have a bit of mixed
technology today as John mentioned were
on the way down we've we've had three
years to think about what types of
learnings we've we've you know we could
are no worthy here a lot of you know
downside a lot of upside we said well
let's focus on the top ten upside so we
have a list of those we're going to go
through but to start I'm going to go
through the overview as as the class
started and this is the more
technologically advanced part of it ec
265 was the name of the class of
middlebury college I was a junior and I
was immersed in the social learning
experience where we were dealing with an
offset company called native energy
happened to be up the road you all
studying offsets right now I've heard of
native energy and we can speak to them
later effectively we had some very broad
learnings that came from the class and
we wanted to come up with a way to
engage everyday people on climate change
meaningful climate action the first
learning that came from the class was
whether or not you believed that climate
change was happy climate change was
happening because of the recent science
we've we've heard from the UN or whether
or not you believe that clean energy is
an important endeavor
in order to reduce our country's
reliance on foreign fuels or increase
our national security clean energy was
generally a good thing and I think
across the board even three years ago
people were agreeing that a switch to
clean energy was a good thing so that
was our first learning our second
learning from the class was simply there
are eighty percent of us eighty percent
of the population in the u.s. was saying
they were an environmentalist and and
very few of us were actually going out
to do to change our lifestyles to spend
an extra dollar to to pay for that green
green premium they were besides
recycling there were very few entry
points into being an environmentalist so
both the clean energy learning in and
the barriers to entry led us to this
original idea of simply taking an every
dude at an everyday tool a credit card
and a rewards program in attaching
carbon offsets to it again as we'll talk
about later it was never about to carbon
offsets you know we never wanted to be a
full-fledged carbon offset company this
was another tool for fighting climate
change so before we get into this top 10
list we asked ourselves what got us from
a class project to a partnership with
bank of america and visa and the
consecutive launch of the debit card
rewards program in the credit card
rewards program to warm up I have deep
from my hard drive it's sort of a
corrupt file but John begged me to pull
out this from the old days I have a
video from the end of the class project
and back then I'll warn you this was
called orange card and I'm not going to
explain the ideas behind that marketing
but let's see if this works
here's how it works as much as we try to
reduce our impact on the environment not
completely avoid each years back an
average american household omit them
team tons of carbon dioxide every time
you use your chart you're taking
responsibility build your climate
footprint with each purchase you may
well take a one percenter so that
typically do support Caroline miles
instead invested in cleaning up our
country's energy technology we do this
by buying carbon offsets on your behalf
use environmental investments only
construction of wind farms local biota
Jasmine plants and other emerging clean
energy sources with orange chart power
to erase your climate for granted in
your hand sign up today you would just
like to leave no trace of course you
couldn't sign up for another three years
but that was the idea so you can see
where we started as a class project at
led to a website and we went on to go
down to New York City and present this
idea at a climate conference called
clean air cool planet climate champions
and and we received actually sort of
serendipity serendipitously enough the
same award that Bank of America was
receiving that day for on behalf of
middlebury college as a climate champion
award that connection that we formed
that day as students actually led to the
launch of this card two and a half years
later now as we go through this this top
ten list that we came down came up with
on the rod down here and sort of brought
all of our ideas and learnings over the
last three years together we we try to
also create sort of a logical
chronological order to all this but if
any point you you say where are we in
the story please feel free to jump in we
want to make this as conversational as
possible
so again we're not we're not quite yet
serial entrepreneurs this is our first
the first company we've started but the
first point that we were very sure of
when we began to get ready for this talk
was quite simple make sure you know how
to spell textbox know now that whatever
it was make sure you have a good idea
deceptively simple but this idea of
taking off sets and matching them to
credit card purchases actually began
with a conversation in a conversation
between my dad and I on the morning of
the class where I actually introduced it
to four young men two of which were Jake
and Andy the other co-founder the moment
my dad and I over bacon and eggs said oh
yeah the credit card that could give you
offsets we knew right away it was a good
idea I was assured in my sort of read
using my I guess emotional quotient I
was assured that it was a good idea
after I presented it in a class like
this as the tenth of ten possible
projects for my 45 students in this
class I said oh yeah there's a there's a
final idea here and I described it and I
said if anybody's interested come talk
to me in the hall as we finish up class
four guys came in and approached me and
again to or Jake and Andy and I'll never
forget the moment we were looking each
other in the eye and I said basically
the idea would be a credit card offsets
we could think about bringing a native
energy of course they took it from there
and there was this moment as Jake was
describing on the ride down here when it
was like there was no hullabaloo around
us there were all sorts of students and
we were all looking each other said this
is a great idea and we never really
diverted from that concept that we had a
good idea so I think that was really
critical and it was a big part of
getting rolling right away but that's
point one actually remember we were
whispering at the time because we
thought right there we had such a good
idea we didn't want the other teams to
to hear how cool it was second point and
pull out my list
is you can't fake authenticity and from
the get-go we were students coming out
of an environmental economics class our
passion was in climate change our past
passion and our passion of our clothes
classmates was in fighting climate
change to the extent that we were trying
to go with with no business background
into starting a business in
bootstrapping and putting ourselves
further into debt we truly were sort of
chasing the the ideals that we had
learned in the class from the learnings
in this idea that that this truly would
work it was a good idea the inner drive
of climate change action was was the one
thing keeping us going and it certainly
wasn't funding you know as you'll see
for a while we get to I think eight or
nine bullet points before funding comes
into the picture this is the real fun
part about doing a start-up and and
having an authentic message and really
speaking with passion is in my learnings
was one of the number one things that
was picked up certainly by the investor
community but but also key partners so I
will go on to the next one the next was
to be confident Jake mentioned that a
month after the class ended we
serendipitously were invited to help
Middlebury College receive an award from
clean air cool planet now based on the
road in new canaan connecticut
Middlebury had done enough at the time
to be considered a climate champion
alongside the governor of Maine the bank
of america the city of Stamford and I
think one of their award recipient and
I'll never forget it as as i was called
being a professor who's involved in some
of this stuff about having who should be
at the award presentation a month prior
i immediately said we'll get jake and
andy they've got this amazing project so
when I offered them the idea not only
did they say fantastic but soon they put
together this amazing booth they printed
up business cards they had a you know
panel stuff that we still have in our
office now we feel it's deeply historic
it was still known as the orange card
but there was this air of confidence
around Jake and Andy who at the time one
was a recent graduate and one was still
just about to start his senior year in
college that I'll never forget so when
they were approached by Bank of America
officials fellow named Ingo pool who was
a European who was also sniffing around
to see if there was a market for the
very same product that we had thought
about there was just this sense of yeah
we can do this why shouldn't we take
ourselves seriously so again as somebody
who constantly was in awe of Jake and
Andy and their leadership I think this
was a big part of it a confidence in
what they were doing based on in fact
our first to billets bullets knowing
that it was a good idea and having the
authenticity that the real drive behind
it learning number four was to me
perhaps the most important learning and
one that we had to quickly adapt to
which was to quickly learn how to ask
for help along the way we've had coaches
and professors and teachers and parents
that are lifetime advisors or advisors
for a short period the first thing that
we looked to was to find the smartest
people we could talk to in order to get
critical advice on moving forward John
was you know on the phone with us every
day you know at home at the office on
his cell phone wherever we could find
him we also quickly engaged personal
advisors environmental advisors and
business advisors because coming out of
middlebury college we we were taught how
to think but we were not taught that the
tactics of moving forward on a business
model and that to me building this
advisory board was a great asset to the
company which leads on to the next point
actually I'm going to go ahead and show
you that bored because have you all
explored the website that most of you
something you put up your hand if you
have just I want to get a sense of so a
number of you have sort of seen what's
going on so just to give you a feel for
it
because getting these people together
was was huge
so again here's our website for those of
you who haven't seen it and again you
can go on and get offsets through our
credit card other products we can come
back and show this as necessary but what
Jake was referring to in terms of
learning from others and just getting
rolling was assembling an advisory board
and there are people like Terry Kellogg
of graduate of the som now who runs one
percent for the planet well so long a
great entrepreneurial figure in the NGO
world mini Luber some of you may know
the president of series Bill McKibben my
colleague it at Middlebury an old friend
of mine one of the founders of cap one
Billy parish a Yale dropout the leader
of the climate movement of the youth
climate movement Gus bet someone you may
have also heard of and so that was huge
we had those names up and running within
months I'm just going to sneak behind
you big and so not only were we learning
from them but it gets 2.5 Jake if you
don't mind putting that back up there
sort of telling the world who we are I
think a big part of credibility again
this was still six months before anybody
had signed a check for us was simply
that we had a lot of social capital we
had a network and we weren't afraid to
show it I'm still amazed when i go to
look at new businesses small businesses
even not so small businesses and it's
sort of hard to figure out who the
people are i think it's particularly
important as i think we showed to just
again let the world know who you are and
that instills confidence obviously
there's a big warm glow one can get if
you have people like those i just showed
you on your board lesson number six and
you can't quote us on this we might have
to edit this part of the video but don't
be afraid to waste paper this is not an
environmental recommendation but more an
idea of maintaining often tissy T
throughout the entire business process
nimbleness rather our ability be nimble
was was really one of our key selling
points to an investor and also to our
major partner bank of america and visa
and and for the reasons
reasons following first of all we were
in a marketplace where the consumer set
was largely undefined traditional
marketing demographics couldn't pinpoint
the green consumer it was costing
millions of dollars to tire the
consultants to target these individuals
so having our sort of grassroots know
how John's experience with the youth
climate movement and access to these new
emerging marketing channels made us
nimble and we could we could change as a
small company with that and secondly we
were we were in the marketplace for
carbon offsets a marketplace that was
changing every day and we were not
directly involved in procuring our own
projects but we were going out and
selecting the best projects to meet our
needs so native energy up the road meet
our rigorous carbon offset policy and we
would go out and select with the help of
our close advisors the mouth most
authentic projects within their
portfolio of renewable energy projects
so being nimble was it seemed it seems
like a risky startup kind of buzz word
but it was really one of the most
critical selling points we had and
something we still cherish it's it's
hard to maintain but but important for
us and so the way paper fits in there of
course is that we just had a lot of
ideas being generated and as we were
nimble we could quickly adapt this is as
you're about to hear before anybody had
written us a check this was four months
after the class had ended so by now
we're in the fall of two thousand five
Jake was starting his senior year Andy
had graduated was working for Bobby
Kennedy at the time but they had kept
the pulse of this idea alive and much to
their credit they kept printing out and
and and creating business plans this is
where the paper waste came in but the
idea was that the sort of nimbleness and
the ability to adapt that we hope is
still a foundation of our company was
seen in new business plans changing the
idea something to send our advisory
board show to potential investors we
just kept writing actually I should say
Jake and Andy kept writing and so that's
the aspect of it the relates to the
nimbleness the next point
we've alluded to now a couple of times
is simply just keep on bootstrapping we
have not raised a penny at this point
and honestly I think it might have been
I don't want to discourage you from
applying for those saban award by any
means but it's interesting for me to
reflect on if somebody had written us a
check at this early stage how that would
have changed the trajectory it's a good
idea i'm sure it would have gone fine
but there was something to be about
being so lean and mean that forced us to
concentrate we literally had nothing to
do nothing to work with except our idea
and I think that sort of kept a fake we
can talk about this in the QA but sort
of kept a hunger alive also there was
something that also had to happen Jake
had to finish his senior year at
Middlebury or myself so then I not only
will be trying to create our own human
capital but we're really learnt leaning
on our social capital as we continued
through the winner of Ohio six and turn
the corner into the spring of 06 not not
a penny to our name really my dad one of
the people who would help this idea to
get going and who was a venture
capitalist in his day I grew up just
south of here he would occasionally you
know take us out for dinner or do other
small things like that but but really we
were just sort of on our own and I
actually think ultimately that helped us
because as I mentioned it helped us to
focus and in actually building on that
point when you're really bootstrapping
the passion shows you can even smell the
passion because you've been sleeping in
your office but you know when you when
you have the story of putting your own
startup money into it and and you know
certainly we didn't come with our own
startup money but we came up with our
startup credit cards and it was startup
debt to us you you you have this aura of
bootstrapping but also being able to
really tell your story with passion and
the reason I lead into that is it leads
up to our next point which is never
be afraid don't underestimate the power
of an open door or rather also don't
underestimate the power of passion to
help you open doors very surprising how
many how many top level connections we
could reach out to either on a cold call
or you know close connection through one
of our advisors but but also the
importance of leaving doors open and in
maintaining your maintaining your
options at one point we were we were in
discussions with a group in the
Netherlands who is launching a credit
card called green card visa and and
another emerging group from Scotland in
the UK wanted to run a similar model
over there and they also wanted to
replicate it in the US we came together
in Scotland in 2006 and and kind of came
together and had this idea of forming a
an alliance across startups and you know
over the world and you can imagine how
trying to structure a you know a capital
capital arrangements and the ownership
of a bunch of startups coming together
works out that that never ended up
panning out but the the relationships
that came from that actually led to one
of our connections with JPMorgan Chase
in the US which was you know in a number
of the other banks we looked across the
board in our early negotiations with the
banks so by not burning any bridges and
by keeping those doors open that helped
us move forward and continue to make
connections I think this is a really
important point and i'll just add
something to it as before i go to the
next point i remember years ago when I
and alluded to I was in the Peace Corps
and I was told the power of
informational interviewing upon
returning to the US and I was given this
advice as your informational
interviewing it's a good sign when you
start to hear the same names so if
you're talking to somebody and she
raises the name of somebody you should
talk to you say well I've already talked
to that person that means you're
beginning to form sort of a knowledge
base that's going to help you to get a
job it
by the way fantastic advice this was
what was happening to us in the spring
of 06 one of our first advisory board
members was an old friend of mine Matt
Arnold who was really one of the movers
and shakers of what you are doing now
and in fact a series that brings the som
and the forestry school together Matt in
the late 80s Early 90s fresh with a
harvard business school degree said we
got to get businesses and
environmentalists starting to talking to
each other and he's one of the first of
a few dozen people doing that Matt took
us our idea seriously right from the
get-go and said well I talked to people
at jpmorgan chase all the time I know
what's going on at citibank so we had
some credibility there through his
generosity in his social capital and
then we brought in a colleague from the
UK want to form the name Tessa tenant
and she began to refer us to some of the
same people so suddenly as as as Jake
was getting close to graduation may of
06 my dad generous enough to be the
first official member of friends and
family he wrote us a check for five
thousand dollars upon hearing about this
big gathering in Scotland at a castle
and gleneagles he said we got somebody's
got to go there and we all turn to Jake
because we knew he would be the most
impressive member of our teams and he's
afraid of flying accurate so but it
meant that when Jake arrived in Scotland
and certainly when he returned we were
suddenly part of a conversation that was
literally happening around the world
about the prospect of matching credit
cards to offsets all of this by now we
had an office that was no no bigger than
the little area you see here and still
that was it we had no assets that
changed with with I think a story that
revolves around point nine and to keep
you up with the chronology and the
essence of this point another old friend
of mine of college buddy has been a
really truly been a serial entrepreneur
he had founded three companies before he
was 25 two of them while he was an
undergraduate at Harvard so I called him
one day and I'm walking around and the
kids are screaming at me in the house
and the cat is probably you know doing
something I'm trying to clean up and I
reach
he's driving through boston and i said
got this idea you know i described it
good idea so i could quickly summarize
it and I said wanted to know if you're
interested he said yeah said I'll write
your check for twenty-five thousand
dollars and there we were and not only
did we have some credibility and now
finally have some money in our pocket
but folks that Jake and Andy had been
grooming and talking to members our
advisory board other people in our
Middlebury and other networks now we
could go to them and say hey somebody
else just somebody just wrote us a check
what about you and so soon we had in
that sort of category of family and
friends money coming in enough to say
hey hey wait a minute something's
happened here now I put this under the
heading of know how to listen to
naysayers because that colleague of mine
one of my oldest friends soon came up to
Middlebury and again this is guys got an
extraordinary track record of startups
in the environmental area he's he's
brilliant guy so he spent the day with
us he said you know what he actually
called me after being there he called a
couple of days later he said here so
here's the deal he said I'll give you a
hundred thousand dollars I'll get one of
the top environmental in the country to
be on the head of your board what
somebody who's been there from the very
GetGo an old friend of bills by now he
said I'll do that under the condition
that you all become a nonprofit said I
don't think you can succeed it's a
for-profit we had had a long discussion
about wanting to be a for-profit we
liked what that did to your inner drive
and your motivations and I've worked in
enough of the nonprofit world to see
that things can get pretty complacent in
a hurry so here's a guy offering the
outer thousand dollars and this
incredible advisory board member for
bill to have come in and played a role
in this company as he would have had he
written as such a large check it would
have been amazing and i said no i think
he was stunned because I've always said
yes to this guy got me in a lot of
trouble in college so but I said no
actually we thought about this and and
and we want to go for profit and it was
his long pause on the phone and he said
are you did you just hear me you know
hundred thousand dollars this big cheese
I'm going to help you out and said you
know thanks Bill and thanks so much for
that first check but no and and that was
key to know how to listen to not only
jurors who were telling you something
different we put them in that broad
category of naysayers but also at the
time and this is another part of this
important point there were plenty of
people who are just telling us it'll
never work I mean have you all ever how
many of you have ever faced somebody
when you come up to them with a great
idea and they say it'll never work
probably all of you icy hands going up
and very quickly I learned that most
people in the world are in that it'll
never work category even people you love
and admire and worketh they just at
it'll never work don't listen to those
people but you have to listen to it a
little bit you have to listen to their
objections but if you're sure enough of
your idea you have to take their
objections and turn them into positive
energy Jake had a really fine phrase
that I'm in a paraphrase that he came up
with as we were driving down here don't
let negative feedback turn into negative
energy the trick is actually to take
negative feedback and to turn it into
positive energy for your company I think
that's something we've got to do pretty
well so you can see that idea of dealer
with naysayers who at times may be
allies but then that broader category
people who are trying to discourage you
you've got to figure out how to deal
with them lesson number ten was be
stubborn now stubborn stubborn in
opening doors is if you know we found
that if you went back five or ten times
to the same door tried to lead to this
new connection and you finally open the
door that person was usually very
grateful for having come back and made
the reminder and the follow-up if the
door didn't open sometimes you had
somebody that was angry said why are you
being so stubborn on the other hand
being stubborn during the fundraising
round was the most critical learn
learning for us because they're there
are a lot of there are a lot of startups
in there very few in Vermont especially
angel investors and to the extent that
that's true we were fighting with a lot
of competition when we when we
were at investor forums you know just
being very aggressive about getting
contacts and following up with investors
being stubborn really was sort of a
full-time job while we were raising
money and going into this this friends
and family around as John alluded to we
didn't really realize what we were
getting into when we started raising
money and our first round as John
mentioned his father put in the first
five thousand dollars to get us overseas
and then we really started running out
of money and started calling our close
friends and asking for a thousand dollar
increments in any any legal counsel will
tell you to be very wary of doing
investment at that small of a minimum
but if you're if you're persistent
enough and you know what your goals are
in mind and and you have that motivation
that sort of stubbornness can pay off
and that was a key learning in the
fundraising around and my vision of this
again then now this is the fall of 06 to
keep up the chronology is Jake in this
office day after day week after week
calling people by now we had a goal of
raising a half a million dollars and
Jake just kept at it kept at it he had a
spreadsheet and that was the what he's
alluding to sort of going back to these
doors five six seven times and
eventually it did pay off we all know
that point 11 is is true my favorite
phrase in life comes from Branch Rickey
who brought Jackie Robinson to the
brooklyn dodgers in the late 1940s and i
think it says on his tombstone luck is
the residue of design and that's a
variation on it several phrases that are
out there the harder you work the
luckier you get but we were truly lucky
and to get even as far as we have we had
heard about as an example an
extraordinary woman who had retired from
American Express and Bank of Boston IBM
and was just amazing according to one of
our advisory board members and for about
eight months we had said to this
advisory board member a guy named Jason
elite Middlebury graduate
would you introduce us to this woman
patty prairie and Jason intentionally or
not sort of fending us off and then one
fall day he called and he said I think
patty would love to meet you the three
of us Jake and Andy and I went down with
Jason introduce ourselves to this
extraordinary person patty prairie and
it just something happened we SAT around
her living room their dogs were no going
after their snacks a very sort of casual
Vermont setting and we just casually I
guess we're making our pitch and
something was in the air or just felt
right and as we drove back almost
getting hit by a car I remember on the
come back roads of Vermont we felt like
wow something just happened there we
were lucky because patty just that was
the right moment to reach patty things
were bubbling up we'd already raised
maybe 150 200 thousand dollars maybe
more into that we really now had
credibility and that was right around
the time as patty agreed to come on as
the CEO that we got a call back from
bank of america who said we really want
to talk with you we've been following
what you've been up to we had a website
by now and we think we'd like we're
interested in doing business so now we
had on our team somebody who could
credibly negotiate the very complex
contracts that led to our agreement only
a few months later with bank of america
as much as i admire jake and andy they
never could have done it it took a three
decades of experience with inside of
banks and inside of large firms to know
how to do that and luckily enough patty
came along just at the right time so
that's a big part of this as we all
recognize and and moving on we tried to
keep the distant to 10 points and i
think at one point we were up to up to
baker's dozen and then we knocked back
to 12 a final final point and one that
has probably you have heard before in a
startup experience especially one
dealing with technology or something
with dealing with intellectual property
it's all about focus focus focus focus
and and for us this was very critical we
were not an environmental consultancy we
were not a broad offset provider we were
focusing on getting a credit card lots
of customers on behalf of the bank in
order to make real meaningful climate
inch and now this actually this actually
was an important message for us to
retain this is sort of this outside of
the box thinking that got us to this
original business model in the first
place but but when we got into the bank
negotiations large institutions have
have have councils they pull together
called risk aversion committees and I
think it's probably 20 executives that
sit around the room and everybody from
legal to to brand to to product
different departments and they try to
poke holes in a product and you can
imagine an emerging market place with a
startup that still was raising a angel
round that there were a lot of holes to
poke in this new product idea that that
the bank was working through it was very
important at that point that we did not
change from our original model and we
did we didn't stray from our our focus
of bringing a high quality product with
with high quality carbon offsets not not
something that we could find for two
dollars a ton on some exchange low
quality projects that we couldn't
couldn't tell where the wind was going
up we wanted to bring this authenticity
and we wouldn't stray from the model and
the reason the risk aversion committees
are important here is effectively what
what these groups were trying to do was
pull us back towards a more traditional
model of an affinity card and when it
comes when you really think about the
the business plan that we put together
it wasn't a traditional affinity card we
did not have a list of you know Emilian
constituencies that we brought to the
table like like Sierra Club might when
they came to the bank of america and put
up a card so we we didn't bring those
potential card holders to bear we
brought great relationships great
partnerships and a lot of authenticity
the other type of traditional model was
a co-branded card there were a lot of
these executives in the risk aversion
committees we're looking for an
environmental organization maybe
Greenpeace
they had that have this brand
recognition and our brand recognition
was in the grassroots was within that
within the youth youth movement and we
were building it from an authentic
ground level and and we really stuck to
those original core values and that was
important in the negotiations even and
we did manage to get past a number of
those risk aversion committees there I
still have a lingering headache to this
day from them so that I went down in the
spring of by now oh seven and we thought
we would be able to launch in the summer
and there those committees and other
lawyers and others slowed us down but on
November 29th 2007 so a year in a couple
weeks ago Jake we think was the first
person to actually use a brighter planet
credit card he bought a burrito I think
it was very historic burrito that must
still be in his car because we drove it
down here no I'm kidding but so that
that's the story that's how an idea in a
classroom two and a half years later was
a product in the subsequent year as we
can talk about in the QA as you all see
fit we have launched not just a credit
card but a quite successful debit card
you can now buy offsets directly from us
if your trip to all these wonderful
places are not through us that would be
very scandalous and we're about to
announce some new products we're about
to also announce probably soon a new
approach to offsets because we want to
make sure we're on the cutting edge of
what is still a very challenging and a
wild-west kind of market but just to
conclude before we welcome you all with
question and answer is just very briefly
on our third point we really do hope
that this concept allows for meaningful
change if you go to our website you can
see the wind turbines the methane
capture facilities that our members are
building we've offset 60 million pounds
of co2 and that's growing exponentially
and even more broadly we really consider
ourselves not just an ox
that company so this is the effect we've
had you can see up there a little fancy
graphic we see ourselves as Jake alluded
to as part of this broad movement this
rapid rapid acceleration to clean energy
that we need leadership in in terms of
nonprofits and for-profits and certainly
colleges and universities so I think
we'll leave it at that we'd love your
questions Brian how much time do we have
to go to how that was perfect so we'd
welcome your questions and again we're
very thankful for this opportunity to
share our story and we're going to do
something technical and tricky here with
a microphone oh we do okay how do you
guys hear me um I have a kind of a silly
question about this graphic because I
see graphics like this used quite a bit
and I think they're very effective but
could you explain how you're taking
calculating the weight of co2 here is
that at one atmosphere in a vacuum or
like you know how does somebody
interpret that weight well when when we
when we're talking about the transition
from a way to volume yes you're talking
about a very generic sort of atmosphere
so you know the volume of co a pound of
co2 would be very different than a
vacuum than it would be in a different
type pressure atmosphere so the this
generic calculation has always done it
at sort of our normal living conditions
it's it is interesting to think of a gas
in the form of a wait and and I think
that's been one of the major challenges
that consumers are trying to you know
jump because it doesn't come naturally
it doesn't seem tangible but it
if you're if you're interested we can
share share that math with you you
follow up so I'm just trying to think if
you're trying to fill this building if
I'm trying to explain to somebody what's
going on here and you just have the co2
Monaco acting by itself what's what's
creating the volume of that gas I mean
is there no other gas that would be in
that building that's filling the
building it would just be a vacuum and
you're pumping co2 into that vacuum I
see ya when you when when there
throughout the process of combusting a
fuel say gasoline in coming out of the
exhaust of a car I think a gallon of
gasoline ways something like nine pounds
but when you combust that gallon you end
up with about almost 21 pounds of co2
and in the strange thing happening is
throughout the process of heat the
combustion process you're giving off
moisture in the form of heat and then
you're also giving off carbon which is
connecting with you know to two
molecules of oxygen and so that that
transformation happens so when you're
talking about co2 you're talking about a
much larger bit than this you know six
660 million pounds sounds it grows quite
state we actually tried to do this and
fill up the Empire State Building with
co2 because we weren't quite sure but
they wouldn't allow us for some reason
sir yep hi okay so what I love about
your idea is that it's it's elegant and
its simplicity the concept of adding
offsets to a credit card my question
though then is when you have an elegant
simple concept how do you prevent you
know a big bank from just saying we'll
start a department you know internally
and execute that I mean I don't know if
it's as simple as confidentiality waiver
and then the corollary question to that
on a broader level is when you have a
business with a social and environmental
mission like this in a way do you almost
not want to maintain complete
competitive monopoly over that idea in a
way wouldn't you want to see a lot of
banks and maybe other startups
take up this concept so how do you how
do you balance that those are two great
questions genuinely the bank told us
when we were when they approached us
that we had three assets that they
didn't one was our environmental
credibility our advisory board the
second was our knowledge base the kind
of thing that Jake just Illustrated and
now we have two staff scientists who
were doing this full-time these kind of
addressing these kinds of questions and
the third was that was it was around the
issue of risk so that if if the idea of
connecting credit cards to offsets
turned out to be a bad idea they were at
least one step removed so that's why
they found us attractive your second
point I've never quite thought of it
that way and i would say exactly when we
were starting to launch as jake alluded
to there was some folks in the EU
getting a couple of cards going Wells
Fargo had one going we're all sort of
talking to each other and a funny thing
happened we had through a contact of
mine I had talked with Lorraine bowls
injure who runs the ecomagination and I
sort of had chat her up and I said we've
got an idea of credit card that uh she'd
oh yeah we've been thinking about that
but our lawyers tell us it's impossible
and I said well we've got sort of a
simple idea just you know 100 bucks
charge more or less a dollar goes to
offset keep it simple such a laying out
the snippet of our business plan hoping
at the time this was before we had a CEO
or anything that they would say oh come
on board and will write you a big check
so several months later we hadn't heard
from her though they did put one of her
staff actually was sort of put on an
account to look into us for a while so I
called her mother spontaneously several
months later I said hey Lorraine has it
that credit card oh yeah we really good
idea sort of keep it simple hundred
dollars and you know dollars worth goes
to credits and she's repeating our
business plan and I first was like
outraged but then I felt cool well you
know bring it home so actually so they
did launch a couple of months before we
we did and we hear from outside folks
who are monitoring this that they are
not they're not accelerating the way we
are put it that way
and I think part of it goes back to the
fact that they don't have the
environmental credibility so I agree I
think you put it very well get this idea
out there I think I just wanted if you
could maybe comment on the company
climate cooler and if you like their
methodology if you would see yourselves
doing something along those lines maybe
you can also explain if you want me to I
can go outdoors Michael yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah why don't you explain it and
then we'll talk basically my
understanding is what they're doing is
looking at the actual purchases that you
make and offsetting what the carbon
emissions are of those products not just
a percentage like what your father doing
right so there we admitted and now let
Jake jump in here too but we admitted
the Michael go up there part of our
story and so Michael go up there for
many if you don't know I think he has a
Yale degree and he was in charge of
redefining progress than doing this kind
of stuff for a long time and he was
another person in this global
conversation about doing this and so we
were quickly put in touch with this guy
we talked we would chat it up etc etc
I'll never forget there was one trip
when we were in Washington meeting with
some our advisory board members and Jake
and enter your literally following
Michael around as he's getting phone
calls from Bill Clinton you know and
barely had time for us I must say but so
and then they they went and did this
idea climate cooler and have recently
honestly been back in touch with us and
so we would it would be a wonderful
opportunity to try to do something
together honestly these are difficult
times for startups let's face it I used
to say to Jake and Andy when the idea
began the odds of you succeeding I think
the first dad's I gave them were two
thousand to one and then once they had a
little check I think I said well maybe
it's now you know eight hundred to one
and we boil it down I think now our odds
are about 12 1 I think I think we have
about a fifty percent chance of really
making it but it's tough times and so I
think all of us including Michael and
other groups are seeing maybe they're
our allies out there that we could deal
with and so we're open to that idea you
want to add anything about yeah you know
I mean I dad actually my
model is is is really interesting
because it it it looks very similar to a
card that was finally launched in the
Netherlands green card visa and they
were able to get skew level data to on
credit card transactions to the level of
detail of the item purchased and they
could put it into a number of I think
ten different categories if you're
buying petrol you know there was a
certain carbon coefficient that would be
multiplied through by the by the
purchase total and Michael's doing much
the same thing our early model assumed
that Americans even even Americans that
were getting into carbon offsets weren't
yet interested in really delving into
the details of their footprint so we
just kind of cut that level of detail
out but I think as as we become more
aware in the u.s. that type of model is
really going to be powerful I think
there are a lot of commonalities between
our story and his yep I actually have
two questions for you the first one is
how to use a company deal with the the
perception and transparency issues in
this market you looted earlier that you
know that that it's kind of a wild west
up market right so how do you deal with
that is a company and secondly I'm
actually interested in your company's
sort of profitability model I it's not
yet clear to me how you said you're not
you're for-profit entity how do you make
money I'll deal with the first 2 i'm
going to talk about the person you can
talk about the second so we have a
policy pants there's our offset policy
so when we're at events we have a big
set of you know pair of blue jeans it's
very clever its permanence additionality
new construction transparency and social
value at it though actually we're in the
process of reformulating us it the two
big things in the offset world is
probably most of you know our
transparency and additionality with a I
think the latter being most important a
project that comes along and says I want
to sell carbon offsets but it's people
who are doing the same thing they've
always done a farm that's just farming
the way it always has but
notices that actually somebody tells
them that it the way they do it
sequester's carbon that's no good it has
to be additional in the sense that the
the change that brings about carbon
reductions would not have happened
without an infusion of capital that
comes from from a company like ours
transparency is right behind
additionality as a key thing and we
honestly just spend a lot of time on
this we have without revealing any
secrets we have been in the last several
months pushing our own model very hard
internally putting a lot of staff time
into making sure what we say is true and
to the degree that we have not been
satisfied with that not so much our
product but the process we are
continuing to ramp up so we're going to
have a word to it that will have a new
policy soon that I think will do even
better in the long run this wild-west
market will converge it's starting to
around standards you probably know
there's a gold standard there's several
other standards out there and I think
there'll be a weeding out process as
we've seen in the forest market FSC
basically dominates now SFI the industry
certification approach as more or less
gone by the wayside so I think in the
long run there'll be a guaranteed good
housekeeping seal of approval that will
win because it's the best one and that
process is very much ongoing now but we
have to staff scientists even as we left
this morning i was getting an update
from our CEO about this very issue to
making sure we're the very best because
i think you can only make one mistake
very quickly a competitor terrapass they
they got they had some tough news about
a year and a half ago terms an offset
project that they were trumpeting
Business Week did a big article they
interviewed the farmers and they said we
don't know what you're talking about and
it could have ended that company and
much to their credit they got right in
front of it is we're going to change
everything we're going to have complete
openness give us your questions they
have a blog now and so I think that's it
if they make one more mistake I think
that will that really could hurt them so
we haven't had one of those yet and
we're hoping we never have one but I
think it's that tight of a market Jake
you want to address the profitability
and then we'll see if there's any
follow-up sure there's no profitability
our three years out that's why we're
anticipating that 25,000 we're not right
of course there are there are very few
revenue channels right now it's a very
simple model just as the product
construct is you know spend a dollar on
your card you're getting effectively a
service which is us delivering a certain
amount of carbon reduction through the
carbon market place a lot of what we do
is going out and selecting these
specific projects wind projects
hopefully solar coming up all sorts of
innovative ways to reduce emissions from
renewable energy and by providing that
service we're allowed to sort of take a
cut because you know we're going out and
buying it buying renewable energy
wholesale effectively and then bringing
it to market place so standard almost
retail model we're taking a cut off of
that service and then again we have two
products out the credit card and the
debit card and now there's also a way to
redeem your world points which is
another rewards program for offsets if
we bring customers to the table that's
valuable to the bank there is a nominal
finder's fee available much of what we
brought to the table was this reach into
this emerging these new non-traditional
demographics Rojas it was one you may
have studied called lifestyles of health
and sustainability Millennials is
another the youth climate movement these
are all different marketplaces a lot of
our business model was based on the idea
of going out and reaching into consumer
sets that the traditional bank marketing
tactics hadn't been able to reach into
before
thank you guys both for coming you all
almost answered my question which I was
waiting to hear and I actually was able
to meet with some people from green
order on their G's or through ward cards
and their model as I understand it is
that they basically fond offsets and
they have a certification that comes in
certifies that and part of the problem
that the green order ran into is they
developed and certified the same company
developed and certified the mall right
and just if you could clarify because
you're getting it looks like you're
developing a variety of offsets and if
so if you work with to guarantee that is
it scientists on your board or is that
how is that integrated so the way the
process works is we up to now we have
perjured offsets from the company up the
road from us native energy which is
traditionally rated as one of the best
in the country and so that's been a good
relationship to date as we sort of
project in the future and think about a
broader policy that will involve but not
be restricted to them an evolution of a
company that shouldn't surprise anybody
we will continue to do what we do now
which is a third-party audit and so to
the degree that they were our direct
supplier we have been auditing what
we've gotten from them as one would
expect and I think as I was alluding to
in terms of the other question I think
we'll all be better off when a
third-party standard evolves it seems to
me that the gold standard is the best so
if that is the one at play then will
embrace that it's actually just too
confusing a marketplace right now one of
our potential offset providers a big
player on the East Coast has told us
that approached their thing of adopting
is to say there are three standards all
of which are third-party gold I have it
in my notes I can't remember but to
others that they see emerging based in
the EU and that essentially they'll say
we can provide offsets in any of these
three categories at various price points
knowing that the gold standard in their
opinion is the most rigorous so I think
that's the kind of direction people will
go at it might be that when you're doing
a trip down to Yale and its students
they're saying look we
we don't have a lot of money to throw
around so the price point we can afford
is eight dollars a ton you get a certain
type of offset but somebody else might
be say i'd be willing to pay more
because i get sequestration out of it or
investing in solar projects in new haven
that has a value to me so that's how I
view it a set of third-party certified
products at different price points that
become sort of the coin of the realm
thanks for this I was wondering if you
could comment and your impressions on
one part of the voluntary carbon market
that people talk about and that's come
up and the idea that it's very
innovative and maybe just any
impressions that you have about why
that's happening or what kinds of
innovations are happening made that um
well i think i think that's that's the
most exciting part to us about the
voluntary market place is it's getting
into technologies that perhaps or not
would not fall under these types of
certifications that they have in the EU
that John was alluding to I think we're
going to see the continuation of the
voluntary market place even under
Obama's cap-and-trade system that he's
already already alluded to publicly
because of that reason to go back and
look at new ways to avoid carbon
emissions through innovation and and so
your are you looking at what types of
innovations that we're going to be
seeing through through this marketplace
yeah
you know from a from a non non
technological standpoint there's there's
a lot of innovation in forest offsets
right now we're seeing one of the major
criticisms or critiques rather of of
buying for sequestration offsets which
is you know that the act of living
organization organism pulling co2 that's
already been released into the
atmosphere out and fixing it in biomass
is that there's it's hard to guarantee
the permanence of that project it's hard
to guarantee that that in ten years
there won't be some sort of natural
disaster that let's let the co2 is
released some of the innovations in the
standards are are are basically
requiring that these companies that sell
this type of offset are building a broad
enough portfolio and setting the
discounts such that across the portfolio
the projects will will meet or beat
expectations so even if one forest was
going up in a fire across the board it
would it would meet or beat the co2
reduction estimates I think that's
that's a very cool innovation we're
going to see coming up in the next
couple of years but I'll quickly jump in
on your browser point which I really
appreciate innovative people are trying
innovative stuff in this market and I
think it relates to some of our points
that if you really care about getting
ourselves to clean energy in a hurry the
world's biggest challenge ever one can
argue and you want to do it in the
business market which is a very
important place for it to be done this
is a product that generates a lot of
excitement the idea of matching
purchases to offsets when you go down
and do your class trip for example is a
really good idea and it's sort of ripe
for innovation so I would say it's a
combination of the product itself that
asked for innovation and the kind of
innovative people coming from places
like this and Middlebury that are coming
to it so it's a very nice formulation I
think of what's going on telepaths
started out of a class to you may know
it I think it was a business school
class at Penn so is now going to grill
me about that that be I gave him no no I
was pretty happy with it I actually had
a question that I think you know the jf
and a couple others of the people in
this room and I have talked about
recently which is there's a little bit
of confusion about the legitimacy of
paying for an offset for developing a
wind power project because you're
essentially selling the future offsets
of that project today with no guarantee
one that the project is definitely going
to happen and to that the project is
going to happen at the financial
calculations that you're making at time
zero when looking at the project so I'm
trying we've been trying to figure out
what is the what's the way I'm hoping
this isn't giving away some secret for
you or native energy but what is the way
of really guaranteeing that that money
that goes into native energy for funding
wind projects in particular which are
really high intense you know high
intensity in terms of capital how do you
guarantee the offset quantity in the
future to somebody giving money now well
i mean i think the norman was sure of it
is you can't guarantee it there is no
certainty for the precise reason that
you mentioned a hurricane could come
along and blow away wind turbine so you
need the portfolio approach that Jake is
mentioning however what can you do if
you go to our site you can see the Ray
wind turbine which was a wind turbine
put up for the school district of Ray WR
a why in Colorado that's a wind turbine
that would not have been there without a
partner native energy who came up with
the capital that allowed the the the
school district to
bundle with other capital they got from
from the state to create clean green
energy clean energy wouldn't have been
there without native energy and
therefore our customers so how does the
process work behind the scenes and this
is the job that I have along with Gus
Beth Billy parish Terry Kellogg all with
Yale pedigrees as well as many Luber the
five of us are our project selection
committee the job we have is to dig into
the documentation provided to us by
native energy and soon without a doubt
others and say is this legit what they
do with these future stream kind of
offset in terms of selling now offsets
in the future is put in social discount
rate you just discount stuff in the
future as you all have learned and they
put in another very tough discount rate
associated with risk and they've
followed the carbon neutral network that
started on the west coast by an
entrepreneur named sue hall so if they
think let's say that the wind turbine
based on the alternative coal in
Colorado will upset over the course of
its 20-year life I'm just making up an
arbitrary number a million pounds
they'll upset through discounting bring
it down to maybe 900,000 and then risk
again maybe down to 800 and then they
tend to bring it down even more I mean
so they are very tough on themselves one
of the reasons I was always attracted to
the native energy from the get-go is
that they use tough standards that were
actually brought to bear by
environmentalists but there is no
guarantee so that's why we have to be so
on alert ourselves have to staff
scientists to keep an eye out the r a
wind turbine about which I've just been
talking embarrassingly stop turning in
early August and it actually got out on
some right wing blogs who because I'll
Gore advocates them were attacking
offsets when we were heard about this we
went into action we called native energy
and we said what's going on there's a
video going around the web the thing is
in turning that could kill us well they
got on the phone to Ray turns out they
were missing apart and the suppliers and
said well we can't get you the part for
six weeks and we said that get the part
now and very quickly the part had the
thing was up in
so that's what that's the service that
Jake mentioned that's how hopefully we
will make a profit someday by providing
as close to guarantees not the right
word but as close to an assurance as you
can that this is the best possible
product for doing what you can fine yep
I think they use it's a great question
and I don't know the answer I think they
use a different risk coefficient for the
two technologies but I'll verify that
yeah good question i guess i'd just like
to build on that a little bit then if
when when a company like native energy
is investing in these projects finding
these projects are they looking for
projects that essentially would not be
funded by oh you know a fully
functioning capital market because it's
not cost-effective on its own precisely
are the are the offsets based on the
total cost of the project or just the
excess necessary funding beyond what the
capital markets would provide for that
project in that risk level the ladder
yes yep so I just sort of have a
following question to some you know some
some of the questions everyone who has
asked I'm curious and how you evaluate
projects in terms of financial metrics
like to the extent that you know you
have the difference between a wind farm
an ax and a methane digester which which
happened to have very different capital
requirements do you look at sort of you
know tons of emission tons abate adverse
you know it relative to the to the
capital expenditure required the
argument being that you you know you
want in an in an ideal world you'd want
to fund projects that emit the most for
the least amount of money or do you look
at things like you know other social
metrics like you know it maybe maybe
wind farms are sexier projects right so
so the answer is both I'll just quickly
jump in and Jake villain I it's hard for
me not to pick up this chalk and write a
marginal abatement cost curve on the
board
but I'll refrain myself but basically
that's what we're trying to do right is
the best possible one at the lowest
point on the curve though is demand
shifts out prices are going up no
surprise we don't do that though in our
current relationship with native nor I
think in our current relationship with
other potential providers they're the
ones who are deciding is it profitable
to sell this kind of offset at this
price on the wholesale market to us and
eventually through other venues as well
so we monitor that obviously but what
we're trying to do is get the best
possible offsets for our customers yes
at the lowest possible price just like
any other good or service I think coming
back to the question from the back of
the room eventually I see it in terms of
your second good question us being able
to say and this is down the line choose
your offsets and if you want one with a
really high social value added Billy
parish who who is a great product of
this campus he really wants he talked to
me about Yale actually buying offsets
that would be weatherizing and making
more efficient low-income households in
this area which would be just completely
fabulous on any number of metrics but
that might be more expensive I'd like to
see a market where you can buy that kind
of offset again choose where you want to
be if you will on that curve and to go
to give a quick example some of our
projects on the Midwest are on we look
at the power control grid and that's the
regional grid of electricity that
supplies energy to anybody that's
plugging into the wall and in the
Midwest there's a lot of coal so for a
megawatt hour of clean renewable energy
from say a farmer on wind turbine you're
getting almost a ton of associated co2
reduction now if you're in California or
the Northeast where the grids are much
cleaner it can be up to as much as half
of associate co2 reduction so in the
Midwest that that's a especially where
the projects are getting very little the
cost of the price that a project owner
can get for their for selling to the
grid is very low and in the benefit to
the carbon reduction is very high that's
a target target area and again looking
in New England where
have renewable portfolio standards in
place Massachusetts utilities are are
required I think to purchase ten or
fifteen percent of their power from
renewable sources or they have to pay a
tax of five cents per kilowatt hour and
that drives price up to just below five
cents because you know if they if they
didn't meet that if they didn't meet the
ten percent they would just if the price
were more than five cents they would
rather simply pay the tax so that's that
sort of man handles the economies of
that and brings the price for renewables
up so in New England it's very hard to
find quality carbon offset projects
because of that reason be sorry because
the projects already get substantial
funding from the sale of Italy good I'm
really sorry if sorry if you partly just
answer one of my questions because I was
just jotting down I thought so I had two
questions one was you mentioned a
turbine possibly being out of commission
for a few weeks and do you extend the
project life of the turbine should that
happen in factor that into your
calculation I was curious what the
project life of the turbine is do you
estimate it conservatively in order to
take account or technical failures and
the second question was do you have a
threshold for a minimum roi some kind of
return that the commercial investors
expect and then when the project can't
meet that you will step in in order to
produce that ROI for them that will then
enable the project is that how you then
that's not that's not the way we are
calculating the service we provide it is
embedded I think in the way that our
wholesale providers are doing so we're
not doing those kinds of calculations
but we would look to our providers to be
doing those right because again they're
offering us all sets at a price point
any good offset policy which is the one
that we have and we're making even
better should do exactly what you've
said if a project stops going we extend
the life of the project so the answer is
yes and the answer is yes to your other
question related to wind if you had us
to question about discounting and under
estimating the life of the project which
we also do that's probably what I had in
my head in terms of the third way we
discount yep this is a tremendous
opportunity for us and stay in touch
with us we are we have the various cards
to pass around but more generally visit
our website and keep asking good
questions and we'd love to hear about
your ideas and stay in touch have
another excuse to come down and we
didn't get to go to pepes this time so
next time we're going to tullys tonight
okay so let's thank dr. Newsome in
Cinque thank you